[Musik]
lockangebote ohne ende aber keiner kommt
so sieht es in vielen deutschen
einkaufszonen aus auch wenn es nicht so
kalt ist minus zehn grad in günzburg
einer kleinen bayerischen stadt da traut
sich nur aus wer dringend etwas braucht
schon nächste woche soll es für mich
losgehen
ich will in den skiurlaub und das wird
bestimmt teuer
menga jv alpina ich wollte noch mal ganz
schnell gucken wie viel das ich habe
also bei der konkurrenz kostet was
kostet denn bei uns kostet der helm im
moment 129 im sondern 109 und 226 euro
119 106 müssen sie halt jetzt wenn sie
wirklich im internet nachschauen haben
sie halt nirgendwo die gewährte ihnen
von der größe her passt hier haben sie
den in der größe den sie genau brauchen
und sie bekommen und sogar mit beratung
ja aber wenn ich das online bestellen
dann kann es natürlich auch
wir liefern lassen und ja zurückschicken
ist überhaupt kein problem das können
sie für uns genauso gehen sicher fragen
eine website wie er in günzburg de und
dann kriegen sie den helm winsen heute
bis 16 uhr 30 bestellen sogar noch heute
geliefert
[Musik]
wir in günzburg de gibt es seit einem
halben jahr 50 händler
tausende angebote nicola tesch hat die
seite aufgebaut ist ganz günzburgs
antwort auf amazon unternehmen nicht in
diesem sinne sondern diese website ist
wirklich einfach dazu da sich online zu
präsentieren
die kunden kommen sowohl aus ganz
deutschland als auch aus günzburg wir
haben aber kann das den umsatzrückgang
durch bestellungen bei zum beispiel
amazon stoppen im buchladen wo auch
schulbedarf wie ranzen angeboten wird
erfahre ich einen weiteren trick der
kunden wenn man den barcode fotografiert
was passiert dann herunter ja dann ist
es so dass sie heutzutage software haben
wo automatisch dann hier das produkt im
internet angezeigt wird es gibt also
kunden die in den laden kommen sich die
produkte anschauen und dann wenn ihnen
das produkt gefällt fotografieren ist
natürlich schön dreist also ich meine ja
sicher man lernt dass manchmal auch
beide teams klar aber das ist halt heute
so ich habe hier in münster raum an den
geschäftskollegen getroffen die mir
gesagt hat eine frau hat zehn rosen an
gruppiert und am schluss hat das foto
gemacht nur gesagt die beständig jetzt
im internet hermann hutter ist deshalb
schon seit jahren selbst im internet
aktiv er hat ein eigenes lager mit
hunderttausenden artikeln
die leute gehen immer seltener in die
stadt sagt er und das hat folgen
wenn man nicht in der stadt ist kann man
keine impulskäufe machen
70 prozent aller käufer sind wie
impulskäufe und damit quasi wenn ich
nicht den mantel kaufe nicht in die
stadt fahre habe ich auch nicht die
chance ein buch oder in stift zum kaufen
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite sind die kunden
dank internet so gut informiert wie noch
nie wenn sie in den laden kommen und
davon profitieren die händler auch in
diesem beim laden fahren kunden gezielt
nach produkten probieren den wein und
lassen ihn sich dann zu schicken
ich habe nur italienische weine davon
aber 1800 verschiedene aus allen
regionen italiens von nord nach süd über
die insel
sie finden bei mir rotwein weißwein rosé
weine und schaumweine auswahl die man
sich normalerweise nur in großen städten
findet biete ich hier in günzburg in
relativ kleinen stadt
das geht aber nur weil ich eben die
kombination betreibe zwischen
stationären handel und online handel
ohne den online-handel im hintergrund
könnte ich kein so großes sortiment
vorhalten und könnte auch die günstigen
preise nicht anbieten
was soll ich denn da für neun euro 80
wenn ich das jetzt in berlin bestellen
würde wir wohnen ja in berlin aber wie
viel würde ich dann dafür bezahlen
überhaupt kein problem sieht sollen auch
neun euro 80 dafür sie bestellen ist
über die plattform wie in günzburg jetzt
verschickten wir die ware
versandkostenfrei innerhalb deutschlands
dank internet haben die läden jetzt eine
echte überlebenschance
[Musik]